tell me the story on how uh because
you've told it before but like the
London record is one of my favorite
joints you put out you did a great job
on that record thank you yeah it was I
[__] played the [__] out of that on
the radio
um but how does Cole end up on that
particular song where you're doing the
whole London thing it's crazy because uh
we went to the studio to go meet Cole
for a whole completely different song
and um before we were on our way out I
was like hey can I play you something
like I'm you know I'm working on my
project I want to play this song and
he's like yeah go ahead I pressed play
and he loved the song He's like I love
the song this is good like
um
I was like okay you know what that's
like he just seemed like he really liked
the song and I wanted to send it to him
like some random day so like two weeks
later I think a month later I said it to
him and I was like hey just sending you
this if you want to listen to it if you
want to check it out since you said you
liked it you listen to it in your car
your bike ride at the gym like whatever
you want and um yeah it just ended up
working out like that like he ended up
liking the song enough that he wanted to
put a verse on it and I was so happy
about that because
like look at that verse it's like one of
my favorite verses of all time oh he
killed it he got off how could I just
seen this one and that one I can have
both oh my God he got oh he did not give
you the throwaway covers I don't think
he has those by the way I feel like
every time he gets on some [__] he
bodies it he does and I honestly wanted
to I was like yo I'm gonna go because
when I first cut the record London it
was like a vibey fun record like me and
Aziz we just have fun like if you know
us we go to the studio and we just try
to have a good time so we weren't oh we
don't really try to overthink anything
or try to make a a hit or try to make a
certain type of record we just catch a
Vibe so I wasn't overthinking or like
pushing my pen to the to the bars like
expecting to get J Cole on that song So
when he put his verse on it I'm like I'm
gonna go redo my verse they're like he's
like no no no they wouldn't they told me
not to they were not supposed to do it
yeah that's kind of like uh cheating but
like yeah I was like bro like who who
thinks when they cut like a random
reference that Cole's gonna be on that
song yeah it's crazy I think that's
against like unsaid rap rules too like
if you send a record in with your verse
and then it comes out and your verse is
way different
it's fine I think that I think that
might have been the root of the whole
like cannabis LL thing back but I didn't
do it because I didn't want to change
the the essence and the energy because
you know sometimes they got that a
certain like energy to him did like
anybody in London like feel like you're
appropriating their accent
I mean nobody said that to me but I just
wonder because everyone's so sensitive
these days and like you know I have a
shout out to England the colonizers of
all colonizers you know but
um I just wonder if they had like you
know yo what like you're taking our you
know I mean I got so much love in London
such a great record like I love London
so much and it became like my second
like I want to say like my second or
third home because I was traveling to
London so often around that time so when
we when it came time that I did London I
was just so inspired by the culture yeah
so I was just like how can I put this
culture in a song without trying to like
piss anybody off but still make it my
own you've worked with Pharrell
and you have the new record where you're
working with Timberland and shout out to
Timberland in my opinion he's he's my
personal
he's not my favorite but he's Timmy the
goat because I think his range is so
crazy but uh what was it like what's the
difference between working with Pharrell
and Timberland who are on the Mount
Rushmore of the producer game you know
um they're completely different people
they're completely they have completely
different like Styles and approaches I'd
say like I mean
they both the one thing I do say is like
similar when it comes to like great
great great producers is there very much
like into the vibe like whatever there's
like an energy you know what I'm saying
the vibe has to be good for like the
vibe has to be right so
um there I'm just so grateful that I've
worked with both of them because they're
so different
I can't say like really what
what about the process are you like
either of those guys have you cooked up
from scratch with them are they just
playing you like a folder yes we cooked
it from scratch
um many times yeah
oh nice well that weekend that I worked
with Timberland it was the week in art
baso
we cooked up from scratch and then
there's been many times I've cooked up
from scratch of Pharrell nice
how was our basil our best was Vibes I
like our puzzle I'm not really that like
too too into art I don't know enough
about it but I appreciate it
yeah I guess that's fair I feel like I'm
the same way yeah I appreciate it I'm
buying it but I appreciate it I'll buy
like a you know a print of it yeah you
know no I won't I'll buy like that like
that's art like a dude redid the
Wrestlemania 13 poster so I bought it
you know and I appreciated it or like if
there's a what about if there's an
artist that you that you're like oh I
like your workout so I'll buy it and
support and like grab a piece sure if I
know the artist yeah I don't know any of
those people yet
um so all the artists need to hit you up
on Instagram and show you that I get
though it's got to be fly you know it's
got to be like there's some good art oh
for sure some of the [__] I don't get
though if I asked you know take it
yourself like the plain spatter is not
your stuff no I don't get it